Let's take a look again at our example.
We see that the condition in here not only handles double quotes but also single quotes.
Question is, is there a difference in how the condition handles double quotes and single quotes?
We still have this hypothesis characterizing the error.
Let's see whether it generalizes to arbitrary quotes, that is general quotes are stripped from the input,
whether they'd be double or single.
In order to check this hypothesis, we now use an input foo in single quote
and we expect the output to have single quotes as well in the output as what's happening in here.
Here again we have our program.
We now need to remove these assertions in order to restore it to its original state.
And now, we're going to invoke this with foo and single quotes
and again, we need to enclose this with quotes to make this a Python string.
General rule of thumb, if you have single quotes in a Python string,
we need to enclose it in double quotes.
If you have double quotes in a Python string, we need to enclose it in single quotes.
And if you have both, we need to come up with an additional multiple strings
enclosed in single quotes and double quotes.
So, here we go, we put in foo and single quotes into the program and now let's see what happens.
Surprise--what you see here, if you put in single quote, they are not stripped
whereas just to recheck, double quotes; however, are stripped from the input.
That's and important end. Double quotes are stripped and single quotes are not.
So the output actually contains single quote which means that our hypothesis as up here
as up here is rejected--the single quotes are not stripped.